paula es colombiana y renunció a su
puesto de trabajo hace tres semanas está
esteticista trabajaba a las afueras de
nueva york a una hora de su casa en tren
el salario era bajo y durante la
pandemia se dio cuenta de que no le
compensaba fue entonces cuando pensó en
crear su propio negocio
entonces yo dije pues déjame inventarme
algo y empecé aquí en mi casa compré mi
camilla compré mis
equipos como lo es acá empecé en eeuu
cada mes cerca de cuatro millones de
trabajadores abandonan su empleo el
motivo de esta gran renuncia dicen los
expertos es el agotamiento laboral el
ahorro que algunos han conseguido hacer
gracias a las ayudas económicas por
parte del gobierno y en otros casos a un
reajuste en las prioridades personales
después de haber superado una pandemia
que ha matado a más de 800.000 personas
en este país la peor parte se la llevan
las empresas no encuentran trabajadores
y muchas están perdiendo dinero como
ocurre en este restaurante de manhattan
antes de la pandemia aquí trabajaban 46
personas ahora son sólo 30 y marcó su
propietario tiene que arrimar el hombro
porque no dan abasto la demanda nuestra
pues ahora casi está a los niveles de
antes de kobe tenemos una segunda planta
que no podemos abrir porque tampoco
tenemos el personal para asistir en el
servicio desde el otro comedor en la
cocina se hacen horas extra para
compensar la falta de trabajadores
durante el periodo de kobe cuando todos
los restaurantes estaban cerrados muchos
de estos profesionales se fueron a otra
industria muchos de ellos decidieron
pues yo ya no quiero trabajar fines de
semana voy a buscarme otra otra
oportunidad es la nueva economía mucha
oferta pero escasez de trabajadores que
ahora tienen el poder de negociar sus
condiciones porque son más necesarios
que nunca